okay for the second day in a row exactly
as the time lag hypothesis would predict
Texas set another single day death
record yesterday remember that cases
started spiking in Texas around mid to
later June like June 16th to 18th we
anticipate typically a 19 to 21 day lag
time between cases and deaths and so if
cases start to spike between June 16 and
18 we would expect deaths to spike right
now and that's exactly what happened we
had a then single day death record in
Texas of 85 deaths on Tuesday and then
yesterday an even bigger number of 50%
bigger 121 deaths yesterday so this does
not bode well for the next 10 days
because the new cases were actually
twice as high last week in Texas than
they were back in mid-june very very
ugly also notable that Florida the other
state along with Arizona and California
that's seeing huge numbers of cases
Florida today as of noon had already
gotten a new single day death record
only as of noon so things are looking
very very bad now meanwhile in Oklahoma
you might remember that Donald Trump had
a rally in Tulsa Oklahoma a couple of
weeks ago Oklahoma set a new case record
yesterday with 858 cases in one day
which probably is not coming as a shock
to too many people so what's important
about this is that when we saw the cases
start to spike but not the deaths the
most easy explanation the most easy the
easiest argument to make was there's a
lag between cases and deaths it's about
20 days there were other ideas thrown
out and I've mentioned some of these
ideas to you before it's it's younger
people getting the virus so the deaths
aren't going to spike because young
people tend not to be as affected by the
virus we're doing more testing meaning
that on average the people being tested
are healthier so even though there are
more cases being reported we're not
actually going to see as many as many
people died States could be lying and
it's still not clear that states are
being totally transparent and you know
all these different ideas the virus
mutated and become less serious it's
sadly and tragically is looking more and
more like the explanation is the
simplest one which is cases started
going up sometime between June 16 and
June 20 depending on the state and 20
days later which is now we're starting
to see the deaths spike now meanwhile
and I'm going to have more coverage of
this on tomorrow's program meanwhile
Donald Trump wants kids back in school
he wants all kids back in school in
person
despite the medical community saying
this isn't safe despite public health
officials expressing concern about
sending all kids back to school despite
a number of summer camps having to be
shut down because so many people so many
kids have gotten the virus including in
I believe it's Arkansas Missouri and one
other state at least has had to shut
down summer camps and the projection
coming out of Donald Trump's mouth
lately is truly stunning he said earlier
this week that states are keeping
politically are keeping schools closed
for political reasons he even tweeted
yesterday quote in Germany Denmark
Norway Sweden and many other countries
schools are open with no problems the
Dems
think it would be bad for them
politically if US schools opened before
the November election
but is important for the children and
families may cut off funding if not open
now
Sweden aside Sweden's having problems
the other countries Trump mentions dealt
with coronavirus the reason that schools
are opening in those countries is they
have so few cases Germany Denmark and
Norway had at most a couple hundred or
new cases a day recently or even like in
the teens or just double digits we have
60 thousand new cases a day so if you
want to be doing what Europe is doing
you should have handled coronavirus like
Europe did from the beginning now I also
can't ignore that Donald Trump is
threatening schools with pulling funding
if they don't open Trump said he doesn't
want to make this political he said that
earlier this week he says he believes
schools are being kept closed for
political reasons but Trump has
identified that he believes schools are
being kept kept closed
to hurt him so Trump is now saying we
don't want to make it political but
we're gonna force you to reopen schools
under penalty of pulling funding because
he believes it will help his reelection
if schools are open that's making it
political which he claims schools are
actually doing consider also this
incredible hypocrisy if it's too
dangerous for Paul Manafort and Michael
Cohen to be in prison because of
coronavirus how is it safe to reopen
every school and I know some of you will
say but David Michael Cohen is not an
old guy but he's older than kids Paul
Manafort is even older I think man
affords in his 70s kids are not as at
risk when it comes to spreading and
serious cases of coronaviruses people
Paul Manafort stage that is true but
what about the teachers what about the
parents and tens of millions of children
going back to school are going to put
millions of adults at risk and and I
want to be really clear I get
economically the importance of opening
schools a lot of parents can't work if
their kids aren't in school because they
can't just afford childcare so even if
every single day you know full-time
childcare so even if the job has
reopened for the parent they may be
unable to work if their kids aren't in
school I get it but we have to be
sensible if schools had to close when
there were 100,000 active cases in the
United States how can you say they
should open when we have a million and a
half active cases in the United States
which is roughly where we are estimated
to be right now I'm struggling with the
math of it and tomorrow on the program
at the top of the show tomorrow because
of the Supreme Court decision on Trump's
taxes we just ran out of time tomorrow
we're going to talk more about the case
for opening or not opening schools
almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
and news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile
app that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's totally
free to use it's a great tool to have on
your phone news voice is not funded by
advertisers or corporate in
the platform is supported by
contributions from users like you the
news voice app will have some really
excellent new features soon specifically
for the 2020 election but they're
wanting to expand their team of
independent journalists in order to keep
everything running they're offering
special rewards to anyone who wants to
give to their new Kickstarter campaign
which can be found at news voice dot-com
/ kik giving a contribution will come
with rewards like insider access to
group chats with news voice staff
members as well as access to a variety
of special features go see what news
voice is all about